ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse bonsoir bonsoir pour mener
avec moi cette interview Corinne Jean
Joseph bonsoir bonsoir Christelle
bonsoir Monsieur le Ministre alors vous
êtes arrivés à un chez nous hier pour
une visite de 3 jours ma première
question concerne les enseignants néo
tuteurs
de concours
c'est lauréat des concours de
recrutement sont souvent nommés dans
l'Hexagone même s'il existe parfois des
postes vacants ici dans l'Académie de
Martinique le député Marcelin Nadaud
attend encore un rendez-vous avec vous
pour faire évaluer la législation à ce
sujet qu'en est-il un mois après la
rentrée scolaire j'ai reçu le député
Nadau comme de nombreux députés
ultramarins dès le mois de juin quelques
semaines après mon arrivée je l'ai vu
encore aujourd'hui à deux reprises et
donc nous travaillons à cette question
c'est une question très complexe d'un
point de vue juridique et d'un point de
vue réglementaire elle ne peut pas se
régler en 5 minutes
que j'ai annoncé hier aux élus c'est la
constitution d'un groupe de travail pour
que nous avantions ensemble sur cette
question de manière à ce que quand je
reviendrai à la Martinique au mois de
mai prochain nous puissions arriver à
une solution stable mais je j'insiste
sur ce point c'est que d'une part les
néotitaires ne sont pas très nombreux
dans ce cas précis et d'autre part il y
a dans l'Hexagone des enseignants
martiniquais ultramarins qui attendent
de revenir en Martinique et donc il faut
aussi tenir compte de celles et ceux qui
espèrent pouvoir obtenir un poste en
Martinique en Guadeloupe ou en réunion
alors justement monsieur le ministre ces
enseignants qui sont déjà en poste dans
l'Hexagone peut faire usage du centre
des intérêts matériels et moraux est-ce
qu'il aurait uniquement réservé ou
est-ce que les néotitaires peuvent en
faire usage pour obtenir leur
affectation en Martinique
les néo titulaires peuvent faire usage
du CIM qui apporte des points néanmoins
celles et ceux qui sont installés dans
l'Hexagone bénéficie non seulement du
CIM mais il bénéficie aussi de leurs
années d'ancienneté et également d'une
d'une ancienneté si vous voulez par
rapport à la demande qu'ils ont effectué
si je pouvais régler la situation des
néo titulaires très rapidement je le
ferai bien entendu et je le ferai avec
grand plaisir mais encore une fois cette
question là est une question difficile à
régler nous y travaillons avec les RH du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
nous allons montrer également aux élus
ultramarins à quel point cette question
est une question complexe qui concerne
peu de monde en réalité mais je conçois
que les personnes concernées évidemment
ont des difficultés
plus des familiale se déplacer c'est une
question difficile ça je j'en suis
d'envisager un jour on ne sait pas en
tout cas une réforme qui permette de
localiser ce concours national c'est un
concours national et nous avons besoin
dans des académies déficitaires par
exemple les académies de Versailles et
de Créteil nous avons besoin
d'enseignants donc la dimension
nationale à laquelle les organisations
syndicales sont très attachées par
ailleurs est une dimension importante
néanmoins nous pouvons la moduler et le
CIM auquel vous avez fait allusion
précisément module la dimension
nationale du concours il nous faut
trouver une voie qui maintiennent la
dimension nationale du concours tout en
faisant de telle sorte que la situation
des ultramarins s'améliorent autant que
possible en priorisant de toute manière
l'intérêt des élèves puisque il s'agit
d'abord d'avoir un professeur dans
chaque classe on va parler d'une autre
problématique la revalorisation de 3,5%
des salaires d'enseignants elle est
contestée par les intéressés une vraie
déception distille je cite même pas de
quoi compenser l'inflation est-ce que
vous entendez ces protestations on sait
aussi qu'il y a
une étude qui a été lancée il y aura des
conclusions qui seront qui sont attendus
pour mars 2023 mais est-ce que vous
entendez ces protestations écoutez le
budget du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale augmente de 3,7 milliards
d'euros il atteint presque les 60
milliards d'euros cette année c'est une
augmentation inédite dans l'histoire de
ce ministère
6,5%. l'essentiel sera consacré à la
hausse de la revalorisation des
professeurs et comme le président de la
République s'y est engagé c'est une
hausse en moyenne de 10% qui peut être
supérieur en réalité pour les
enseignants qui ont 5 à 6 années
d'expérience on parle là de 13 à 14%
d'augmentation et si on ajoute à cela
les missions nouvelles que nous allons
proposer aux enseignants nous allons
parler avec les organisations syndicales
ce sera encore 10% supplémentaires pour
arriver à un total de 20 à 25% de hausse
de salaire on est bien au-delà de
l'inflation c'est quelque chose de
significatif qui est tout à fait en
phase avec ce dont nous parlions il y a
quelques semaines c'est à dire un choc
d'attractivité pour attirer à nouveau
les candidatures d'enseignants et faire
de telle sorte que nous ayons
suffisamment d'enseignants titulaires
dans l'éducation nationale alors
maintenant monsieur le ministre nous
allons nous intéresser un petit peu à
nos élèves le niveau scolaire des élèves
martiniquais beaucoup plus bas que ceux
de l'Hexagone d'ailleurs selon un
rapport de la Cour des comptes daté de
décembre 2020 25% des petits
martiniquais qui entrent en sixième
présente une maîtrise insuffisante ou
fragile du français contre 8% en moyenne
dans l'Hexagone avez-vous déjà
identifier ou vos prédécesseurs les
facteurs qui expliquent ces différences
de niveau il y a un facteur général qui
est que l'école française le système
scolaire français a du mal à compenser
ou à effacer les inégalités sociales et
donc si il y a bien un écart et vous
avez raison de le noter entre la
Martinique et l'Hexagone cet écart est
d'abord dû à un écart de richesse
général à un pourcentage de population
pauvres plus élevé en Martinique que
dans l'Hexagone à une éducation
prioritaire qui représente à peu près la
moitié des élèves martiniquais c'est
beaucoup plus que du côté de l'Hexagone
donc il y a d'abord cet écart si vous
voulez du point de vue des inégalités
sociales donc ce que nous devons faire
bien sûr c'est plusieurs choses d'abord
investir et continuer à investir du côté
de l'éducation prioritaire ça suppose
aussi revoir la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire qui a qui a vieilli ces
dernières années compte tenu des
évolutions de la population c'est vrai
d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble du pays ça
signifie aussi poursuivre les efforts
qui ont été entamés du côté de l'école
primaire avec le dédoublement des
classes par exemple dont on devrait voir
les premiers effets significatifs pour
la sixième des cette rentrée et puis ça
signifie travailler notamment sur les
classes charnières la classe de 6e par
exemple est une classe absolument
décisive parce que c'est là que l'on
voit les trajectoires divergées entre
les élèves qui vont s'en sortir et ceux
qui envoient qui vont avoir des
difficultés monsieur le ministre
justement sur ce point faut-il à votre
avis un enseignement adapté à nos on
sait que les outre-mer ont chacun leur
propre spécificités chez nous la
Martinique qui est marquée par un déclin
démographique nous avons de moins en
moins d'enfants de plus en plus de
seniors faut-il adapter justement notre
éducation par rapport à tout ce qui
constitue notre environnement
socioculturel
l'intérêt du Conseil national de la
refondation dont le reportage parlait en
tout cas dans son volet éducation c'est
justement de permettre aux communautés
éducatives locales dans chaque école
chaque collège chaque lycée de prendre
de penser le projet pédagogique qui est
le leur avec des particularités en
tenant compte des spécificités locales
et donc plutôt que d'imposer une réforme
par le haut depuis Paris on fait
confiance aux acteurs locaux on fait
confiance aux enseignants équipes
administratives aux parents d'élèves au
périscolaire pour justement adapter
ce qui doit l'être et favoriser la
réussite des élèves donc vous voyez on
s'adapte à cela et puis j'ajoute aussi
l'intérêt mon intérêt personnel pour
l'enseignement bilingue et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le voir à plusieurs
reprises depuis mon arrivée
l'enseignement du créole est aussi une
particularité de
l'outre-mer par rapport à l'Hexagone et
cela est évidemment une très bonne chose
parce que cela ne se fait pas au
détriment de la langue française ça
valorise les cultures locales tout cela
est très bien alors est-ce que on
parlait des craintes tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il faut craindre par exemple
une baisse du niveau scolaire des élèves
et des étudiants qui ont suivi pendant
de très longs mois et scolarité à
distance par rapport à la pandémie c'est
quelque chose que nous mesurons et que
nous regardons attentivement
la pandémie a eu des effets sur la santé
physique et psychique des élèves et puis
bien entendu pour les élèves les plus
fragiles la le rapport à l'école a pu se
distendre et j'en ai eu des témoignages
depuis mon arrivée en Martinique hier ça
c'est un contestable en même temps on
voit comment l'école reprend le dessus
comment finalement avec cette rentrée
qui est une rentrée normale la première
depuis de longues années on voit comment
le système scolaire
fabrique à nouveau les sociabilités les
habitudes scolaires qui avaient pu se
perdre avec le temps donc le temps joue
et puis l'Académie de Martinique a fait
aussi beaucoup d'efforts ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers mois pour une
rentrée sereine et pour rétablir aussi
un dialogue qui avait pu disparaître
avec la crise sanitaire entre les
parents entre les enseignants bref
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
c'est finalement tous l'esprit du CNR
que de mettre des mouvements à nouveau
après la crise que nous avons connue un
monde scolaire qui a besoin d'un nouvel
élan mais cet élan on va le susciter par
le bas avec un financement pour les
projets pédagogiques qui seront
sélectionnés ça n'est pas une discussion
un peu abstraite sur l'école c'est pour
parler de chaque école de chaque
établissement et se voir ensuite
financer le projet pédagogique
lutter contre le décrochage scolaire par
exemple tout à fait lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire lutter contre ce
dont vous parliez c'est-à-dire ces
écarts entre la Martinique et puis
l'Hexagone je vais suivre très
attentivement les débats qui vont avoir
lieu qui ont déjà commencé comme ce
matin justement au collège
je voudrais justement revenir avec vous
sur cette déclaration du président du
conseil exécutif de la CTM de la
Martinique monsieur la chimie notamment
cette activités de Martinique prévoit
dans ses actions 2021-2028 un programme
éducatif de réappropriation de
l'histoire de la culture et du
patrimoine martiniquais alors Monsieur
le Ministre allez vous valider ce projet
d'éducation locale le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale est en charge des
programmes scolaires et nous n'allons
pas reculer sur cette prérogative c'est
le ministère qui définit les programmes
néanmoins il est tout à fait normal et
c'est d'ailleurs prévu dans les textes
encore faut-il qu'il s'applique que les
programmes puissent se décliner
localement et régionalement en tenant
compte des particularités locales de la
riche culture et de la riche histoire de
la Martinique par exemple
notamment l'histoire coloniale et
l'histoire de l'esclavage
dans cette dans cette région et donc ce
que j'ai proposé
au Président les chimie et bien c'est
que nous échange à ce sujet de manière à
ce que quand je reviendrai au mois de
mai nous puissions le cas échéant signer
une convention par laquelle le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale tiendra
peut-être mieux en compte c'est
particularités de la Martinique qui me
semble être des atouts en réalité pour
cette région mais nous gardons la
prérogative qui est celle d'établir les
programmes mais nous le faisons en
dialogue et en con et en conversation si
vous voulez avec la collectivité une
autre question qui concerne la prise en
charge des enfants porteurs de handicap
handicap visible ou pas qu'est-ce qui
peut être mise en place pour pouvoir
améliorer leur accueil je pense aussi à
la formation des enseignants ou des
aidants
nous avons créé à cette rentrée 4000
postes d'accompagnants qu'on appelle les
aesh qui s'ajoutent à la croissance très
importante du nombre d'aidants ces
dernières années on en est à 130 000
pour un total de plus de 430 000 enfants
en situation de handicap et donc on a
une difficulté qu'il faut reconnaître ce
sont les notifications qui arrivent de
façon extrêmement importante et notre
difficulté à répondre à ces
notifications pour des besoins qui sont
des besoins très larges dans le monde du
handicap donc il nous faut réfléchir
structurellement avec les départements
les maisons départementales du handicap
pour savoir comment on s'organise pour
faire face à cette demande continue à
laquelle nous avons du mal à répondre
objectivement et parallèlement nous
devons aussi mieux former nos
enseignants pour accompagner les enfants
à besoins particuliers donc nous avons
nous un effort faire mais c'est
l'ensemble du système à la fois le
médico-social et puis l'éducation
nationale qui doivent mieux travailler
ensemble pour répondre à cette
difficulté que nous avons qui est une
difficulté structurelle elle est vraie
en Martinique mais elle est vraie
également dans l'ensemble du pays alors
Monsieur le Ministre on rappelle quand
même que vous êtes quand même une
personnalité vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'histoire sociale également de
l'histoire des minorités des minorités
noirs est-ce que c'est une mission aussi
que vous allez défendre au sein du
ministère de l'Éducation on parle
notamment à on pense notamment à nos
territoires à cette terre d'aimer
Césaire voilà
j'ai un intérêt et une affection
très très marquée pour aimer ses airs il
m'a guidé dans ma vie d'étudiants dans
ma vie d'adultes et d'universitaire et
ce matin au lycée Schoelcher justement
j'ai eu le plaisir de parler d'aimer ses
airs et de montrer comment aimer ses
airs
valoriser la figure de Schoelcher
justement en qui il voyait un combattant
intraitable de la liberté et donc quand
je suis en Martinique c'est d'abord par
la figure d'aimer ses airs que je
réfléchis sur des questions qui lui sont
chères ce sont des questions au fond qui
devraient être celle de toutes les
Françaises et de tous les Français
imprégnés nos jeunes martiniquais c'est
ces questions qu'on attendra peut-être à
oublier aimer ses airs n'est pas oublier
ça j'ai pu le
la négritude les questions qui sont
relatives à l'égalité à la lutte contre
le racisme à la lutte contre les
discriminations ce sont des questions
qui relèvent des valeurs de la
République et en tant que ministre de
l'éducation nationale elle m'importe
grandement même si je les pense
aujourd'hui un peu différemment que dans
le passé lorsque j'étais universitaire
alors demain justement vous rencontrerez
une cinquantaine plus jeune du centre de
formation des apprentis de Rivière Salée
que leur direz-vous j'ai plaisir en fait
à rencontrer les jeunes comme je l'ai
fait à la Réunion la semaine dernière
pour un échange à Bâton rompus sur leur
problème à la fois sur les questions
scolaires pour ceux et celles qui sont
scolarisées mais aussi sur toutes sortes
d'autres questions c'est pour moi une
manière
d'entendre les difficultés de ne pas
répondre à chaque problème
individuellement mais d'abord d'échanger
de prendre en considération leur
difficulté lorsqu'ils en ont d'écouter
de me nourrir aussi des idées qu'ils
peuvent avoir et puis de les rapporter
avec moi au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale je ne peux pas concevoir
les fonctions que j'occupe de manière
purement verticale sans écouter la
jeunesse et donc c'est d'abord pour
écouter pour me nourrir pour réfléchir
que j'ai souhaité rencontrer cette
cinquantaine de jeunes martiniquaises et
martiniquais et je me réjouis de les de
les retrouver demain on a le temps
encore je suis désolé je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas les données concernant le temps
et allez vous rencontrer les enseignants
de la Martinique mon conseiller les a
rencontrés cet après-midi au cours d'un
échange qui a permis d'aborder quelques
questions dont nous venons à l'instant
de parler sur les néo-titulaires ou sur
les revalorisations j'en ai croisé et de
nombreux bien entendu y compris des
représentants syndicaux aujourd'hui par
exemple au lycée Schoelcher mais sachez
que ma porte est toujours ouverte aux
organisations syndicales et depuis
quelques mois nous avons un établi ça
veut pas dire que nous sommes d'accord
sur tout mais nous avons établi un
dialogue de confiance que nous allons
poursuivre dans les semaines à venir à
propos de ravalorisation puisque
évidemment avec le budget c'est la
question qui est à l'ordre du jour et
donc à propos de ces organisations
syndicales j'ai d'ores et déjà un
compte-rendu détaillé des Entretiens qui
ont été menés cet après-midi très bien
merci beaucoup papy ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation sur
Martinique la première Corinne Jean
Joseph merci beaucoup d'avoir mené cette
interview avec moi on vous retrouve un
lundi avec Jean-Marc parti pour
politique pays merci Christelle merci
beaucoup